Would a mega-murderous, universe-killing snap
by any other name sound as harsh?
After the shocking events that played out
in the final moments of Avengers: Infinity
War - you know, when Thanos powered up the
Infinity Gauntlet, then snapped his fingers
and wiped out half of all living creatures
across every galaxy in existence - Marvel
fans have been at a loss as to what to call
the Mad Titan's horrifying act.
While most people have referred to it as "the
Snap" or by the more creative name "the Snappening,"
Thanos is the only character who's bothered
to try to give it a name.
"With all six stones I could simply snap my
fingers and they would all cease to exist,
and I call that mercy."
Unless you're a genocidal monster, though,
that's not the best name to use for it.
For their part, not even Marvel has given
the moment a legitimate moniker.
That is, until now.
Thanks to the publication of the most recent
Avengers: Infinity War tie-in novel, The Cosmic
Quest Volume Two: Aftermath by Brandon T.
Snider, Thanos' snap has an official name
- and it's a brutal one.
To those who survived being snapped out of
existence by the Mad Titan, the act is known
as "the Decimation."
While the Avengers and company clearly know
all the heartbreaking circumstances that surround
the moment - the vigilantes joining forces
in battles across the globe, several heroes
making incredible sacrifices, and many crumbling
away to dust, some in each other's arms - non-superpowered
humans spared by the Decimation won't know
the truth.
"Wait, wh - where'd everybody go?"
In The Cosmic Quest Volume Two: Aftermath,
the Avengers have concealed the truth from
the rest of humanity, believing that revealing
the fact that Thanos was responsible for taking
the lives of billions of people would "hardly
help the world to heal."
No one but Earth's Mightiest Heroes and the
band of Marvel vigilantes involved with the
event know what actually happened.
Everyone else is only aware that most people
in the world have vanished without a trace,
and aren't aware of the reason why.
"Something's happening.”
For comic book fans, the name "the Decimation"
should ring a big bell.
In the Marvel source material, the moniker
was previously employed to refer to the aftermath
of the event that happened in the "House of
M" storyline, which featured Scarlet Witch
stripping powers from 90 percent of the world's
mutants.
The "depowered mutants" suffered terrible
fates after Scarlet Witch wiped away their
abilities, with some fading away and eventually
dying without their powers.
Though it's fitting that The Cosmic Quest
Volume Two: Aftermath would pluck "the Decimation"
name from the Marvel comic canon given its
similarity to the aftermath of the "House
of M" event, it remains to be seen whether
Marvel Studios and directors Joe and Anthony
Russo will implement the name in Avengers
4, or if the heroes will, as they have done
in the comics and this new companion novel,
keep Thanos' snap a secret from humans.
Thanos' snap and Scarlet Witch's power-clearing
in the House of M storyline are incredibly
similar to one another, and it makes total
sense why the heroes who made it out alive
would want to save others from the trauma
of the full story.
But will fans hear that name and witness that
secret-keeping in Avengers 4?
We don't feel like we're reaching in saying
that it's possible, but knowing Marvel, anything
can happen.
Marvel has a tendency to keep any and all
Avengers-related details in near-impenetrable
lockboxes, so to make any confident declarations
about the contents of Avengers 4 would be
silly.
At the end of the day, fans can find out what
Thanos' snap will be called in Avengers 4
when the film opens in theaters on May 3,
2019.